hey guys i'm going to show you guys now
how to change the volume level for
different applications
um so first of all say i have windows
media player open
and i'm playing a song i'll play it
quietly i guess
and
next we're going to have
uh say a web browser open and we're
going to be watching a youtube video at
the same time
as the song is playing in the background
so all these things are happening one a
song is playing i'm also uploading
youtube videos so this might be a bit
slow
and let's just watch one of my videos
real quick
so this is my video on how to use
safari add-ons so that is playing in hd
and
we want to
try and volume down a little we want to
change the volume level in different
applications well what windows vista has
down here
is a volume level changer you'll know
when you left click it once you'll get
this thing right here which changes the
overall volume of your system
uh which is the master volume but if you
hit mixer
you're gonna get
the mixer for all your different
applications so should i get a skype
phone call right now it would ring at 60
volume or 50 yes 60 volume now
and should i get a mozilla thunderbird
uh email incoming it'll ring at a
slightly higher volume say 70. and i'll
scroll to scroll to the right
and say
i'm recording right now at this volume
quick launch buttons which is when i you
know hit the uh
it's an hp thing but i'll go over that
in a later video
here's the youtube video that we're
watching we can turn that down
inside
of
inside of windows basically without
opening firefox and windows media player
will turn it up
and you'll see the you'll see the mixer
show it here and then i'll turn it down
again
and you see how low that is so that's
what's causing most of the volume
and we can click on that
click on it again to open it up
and i'm actually going to go in here and
close it and you'll see
firefox is
actually firefox is no longer playing
any sound and if i should stop this
and even close windows media player
now it's no longer in the mixer
uh so yeah that's how we change the
volume level of different applications
this is the master volume of your
speakers or if you have headphones
plugged in so if i were to drag this you
see all the different applications
increase and decrease accordingly if i
were to drive one application a the
master volume then that means the master
volume must go up
i can drag everything the highest um in
the master volume which i will do
drag everything up to the top
i can still change the master volume to
switch everything lower and change the
entire system sound
say to 80.
so that is how you change the uh the
volume level of different applications
um simply
left click once and hit the mixer button
to access all this functionality
if you want any other tutorials for me
to make just send me a message subscribe
and i will do that for you so thanks for
watching peace